we're going to play now a new quiz on
blixt and the city it's called Mary
murder or make out
I'll give you three names of characters
and go with drones and you have to say
who as King Robert Baratheon you would
like to marry Mirza or make out with
Cersei Tywin and Jaime Lannister marry
murder or make out which want one of
each I think I'd have to murder Tywin
would you marry Jaime or after marriage
marry Jaime and you didn't there with
her fiance yeah
wasn't the greatest success yeah chief
Jaime ago exactly you know you you see
what it's been like with Cersei that's
it yeah no it changed things up a bit
okay he's pretty come on now Daenerys
Renly and Ned Stark
marry murder or make out as a tough
choice isn't it Daenerys Renly or Ned
Stark as Robert are but after murder
Daenerys on sight
can't that leaves me with no don't know
whether I'd be able to marry my own
brother
I'm afraid I'm just gonna have to make
out with a very med quite normal over
game it's definitely over there you know
you get on well with Ned's daddy let me
marry it should be alright final set
this is this is a toughest one part so
far marry murder or make out beerus
little finger and pycelle that small
council for you there you go
small Council alright I'd marry pycelle
because he probably won't be around for
long
I'm sorry Aiden bad after I left the
murder little thing yet we have said
this season that he's the most dangerous
man in Westeros yeah I really don't
trust him and I think Varys probably has
very soft hands so that's a little bit
married I love it I love it King Robert
Baratheon I can see it now
sighs thanks so much mugs Olivia
speaking okay